finlay toyota the sponsors of this next
segment are always giving back to our
community one of the organizations they
work with is best buddies i spoke with
findlay cfo tyler quarter about the
organization and its amazing members
at one of our events uh a few years ago
i met michelle and michelle uh has been
with best buddies and so she
from that conversation we got her come
to work for us here at findlay toyota so
she's been working for us here at philly
toyota for about four years now this is
perfect because anyone that comes inside
findlay toyota they walk through the
door and the first thing they're gonna
see is you yes and they said
goodbye everyone can they help you with
anything she brightens up everybody's
day when they see michelle she greets
our customers she does a lot of data
entry for us and so forth been a great
employee and a great connection for us
with best buddies
okay hey what's up how are you michelle
i'm good nice to see you thanks he's
very nice well michelle what do you like
best about working here at findlay
toyota i love working at philly toyota
everyone i work with i call them my
friends and i want to thank
tyler and
john barr to let me to book
this one for dealership here
i love i love both of them and
i do all of the personal documents from
my supervisor aot
she's amazing person and i love you and
i love working here this is my second
home thank you for calling fellaini
tayola this is michelle speaking how can
i help you tyler what's it like to have
michelle as an employee here well
obviously as you can see she's uh she's
a ball of energy and she brightens her
day and so we just love having her here
and that's why we want to support best
buddies is to help people like michelle
and so we're in this fundraising
competition champion of the year we're
trying to raise the most money not just
locally but nationally raised the most
money for best buddies and so
it culminates in our gala on november
5th over at caesar's palace we're going
to win for sure right we're going to win
heck yeah we are
so that's what we're doing and we're
just trying to raise a lot of money to
support people with intellectual and
developmental disabilities and uh give
them opportunities in life someone's
watching right now and they want to help
out how can they help the cause so they
go to best buddies nevada
champions you can find you just google
it it'll come up our fundraising page is
there so we'd love to have you
five dollars ten dollars fifty dollars
five thousand dollars whatever you can
afford to to donate to help best buddies
we'd love to have you donated on our on
our fundraising page so michelle p
people can donate through your personal
page how do they do that okay i'll just
go on my facebook and you'll see my
phone's page on there
um click on the donate button
if you um want to donate like
like more like
more more
and that will help me entirely to win
because we are going to win the title of
chamber of the year we're not gonna give
up we're gonna fight to the end
i just love her thank you again to
finley toyota for sponsoring this
segment they're located at 7733 east
gate road in henderson for more
information call them at 702 566
or visit findlaytoyota.com